Fuji Hunt, John Flacco speaking.
Hello, John, how are you?
It's Frank.
Hi, Frank, how are you?
Okay.
I guess you're all set and ready to go.
Yeah, I guess so.
Okay, that's great.
I just got back in from lunch and I'm glad everything worked out time wise for both of us.
Yeah, yeah.
You're on the Holo Talk Show, and the listeners will be tuning in to hear all the news about the new Fuji materials.
So it might be a good idea for us to start off with maybe a timeline as far as uh Fuji's development of these materials.
Maybe explain why Fuji even decided to get involved with holographic materials in the first place.
Uh-huh.
Well, basically, um, as uh everybody knows, Fuji is a uh manufacturer, marketer, and uh reseller of photographic films and all kinds of things like that.
And uh they found that uh there was one uh kind of niche market that's out there for films that uh has not really been serviced very much in the past.
It's it's been serviced up and down, different companies got in and out of it, uh supply is is questionable at times, quality goes up and down, so they thought since they have the capability of of coding uh high quality films, they thought uh that's a market they could get into.
Also, there's um uh thought about the future in data storage where you can store uh information on various different kinds of substrates and holography is one of the things that people have talked about.
So um, you know, looking at it as possibly a a twofold kind of technology.
Yeah, so basically with the holographic uh data storage, the uh film based uh holography part of this is actually just Fuji getting your feet wet, really.
It could you couldn't look at it that way.
It's uh it's a possibility, yeah.
Yeah.
And uh when did Fuji start to uh has this been in development for a long time?
Uh I don't think it's been a long time.
It might have been about uh a year.
Okay.
They started to look at the research of doing it and things like that about a year ago, and then they started doing some market research uh probably uh a year ago, uh last summer, so last year, two thousand five.
This I guess the summer fall of two thousand and four, they started to do some market research on it.
That's a pretty quick turnaround time.
Uh yeah.
Yeah, uh I think it uh you know I can't say before that what they were doing or thinking or anything like that, but as far as I know, that's that's how the uh the whole thing worked through.
And again, we have to remember they're they're a photographic company, so they can you know do a lot of the testing pretty quickly.
Mm-hmm.
So let's move on to now that we know that the product has been developed and it's out there.
I'm assuming it's out there.
I'm not sure.
Uh is it's available for order yet or not available.
Not quite there.
Uh we just uh announced it via press release uh from Japan and one from the US itself.
Um our plan is to have a film available by the end of January two thousand six.
Mm-hmm.
And uh that film would be available in uh thirty by forty sheets, fifty by sixty sheets, and uh one meter by uh ten meter length rolls.
Yeah.
And from what I understand from our lunch last week, at this time at least, Fuji doesn't plan on supplying any other formats other than those that you just mentioned.
Right.
At this present time we we aren't because uh of the simple fact that we're we've haven't uh had the film out there.
We'd you know we've done market research and study, we've done a field trial on the test and and stuff, but we thought it'd be best uh to bring it in into what we feel is the commercial market which um uses the largest volumes of film and thus uh once some volumes have been established then we could think about bringing it into sizes like uh your listeners might be using in you know like two and a half by two and a half or four by five or the like and there's always the option at at this point in time for uh someone to order a few thirty by forty centimeter sheets and just cut them down.
Yeah basically that that's a way to get around it.
The minimum uh box uh quantity we'll have would be ten.
So I mean a couple of people could get together and and buy some like that or uh if it's a school, you know, they can just buy one box and it'll probably last them for the year.
Now since since this film is panchromatic is it uh do you recommend any specific safe light or no safe light at all with it?
No you can use a safe light as a matter of fact it's um it dips down at the lowest uh rate at about uh five seventy nanometers so uh we've actually used a very dark amber type filter as a safe light.
Okay.
Uh but we've also found uh that there's a um amber uh LED type light it's uh company called Opti.
Opt LED, I think it's called, and they uh sell an amber uh spotlight, basically, uh that's made from an LED.
Uh that's been used very successfully as a safe light uh by covering half of it with a green filter.
It is very, very bright.
You can actually see in the room pretty clearly.
Oh, that's great.
Yeah.
So we're happy about that.
Or, you know, you could you have to experiment, of course.
So sodium vapor type lights could be used, but they the intensity has to be reduced by quite a bit, yeah, with neutral density filters or some kind of enclosure or what have you.
Yeah.
Now we spoke a little bit last week about comparisons just for general purposes to Agva, and you gave some information as far as an increase in resolution over AGFA, if my notes are correct, but yet the speed is very consistent or maybe one stop difference between AgFA if you want to do that.
We think it's about uh around a half a stop slower than the AGFA material.
Okay.
Um basically uh it resolution is around uh even lines per millimeter would be greater than three thousand lines per millimeter.
The grain size is about thirty to forty uh nanometers.
Okay.
So it's it's not the finest grain in the world, but it's uh very fine grain.
Uh well, I did see some reflection holograms created with it, and they were very impressive.
Yeah, uh some of the things that people have told us about them are that uh very little noise, so you get a lot of really blazing clear image out of it.
And you know, good that of course gives you the good contrast for highlight the shadow.
Mm-hmm.
So that's really good.
And like I said, the brightness is really uh good about it.
Once you do a transfer, it's very, very bright.
As far as processing the film, pretty much any type of processing chemistry that happens to be a holographer's favorite, I understand will uh yes, basically it uses you know the normal process that you would use for holography, you know, doing a a developer and then a bleach afterwards, and uh different people have their own little you know, chemical mixes that they like to use.
Um people use a uh Webster's uh formulation out there, you could use D nineteen, there's different kind of pyro uh mixes out there.
Pyro Pyro was actually always my favorite.
Yeah.
Uh I mean it's a good because it's uh you know, from the black and white film, it's a very uh low contrast, fine grain type developer that gives you a very long tonal range and it uh lends itself very nicely to holographic film.
Do you happen to know offhand any of the specific formulas that uh were being used for the uh testers that they were using?
Um nothing that was out of the ordinary that was uh out uh in the marketplace.
Yeah.
What I mean I can say that um you know, uh as your listeners may or may not know, Fuji Hunt is uh uh the real whole name of Fuji Hunt is Fuji Hunt Photographic Chemicals Incorporated.
And so and we're a wholly owned subsidiary of Fuji Photo Film Limited Japan, and and most of our products that we deal with uh are photographic chemicals like the ones you might see being used in local mini labs or mass retailers.
Mm-hmm.
So our forte is actually chemicals in a lot of respects.
So we will be in future, once we uh you know the the holographic film gets out there into the marketplace, we will uh most definitely be looking at introducing uh total processing systems where it includes uh a developer that's optimized for use with the film, um where you basically just have to add water and you have a developer, and then we want to um produce or provide a stabilizer solution.
'Cause one of the issues that you have with holography is it's not really like a black and white film where it's fixed and washed normally.
People use bleaches and then how do you stabilize the image so it doesn't print out over time?
Yeah.
So we're looking at uh doing something in that vein uh in the future.
Are you are you speaking primarily of uh manually developing film or are you planning on developing some sort of a uh automation system?
We're we're looking at possibly doing some kind of automation uh uh down the line after uh we come up with a regular chemical system.
I didn't mean a system per se as far as machinery goes.
Okay, and more developer and stabilizer developer bleach and stabilizer.
There's an awful lot of old photo typesetting systems out there that uh the laser image centers like the linatronics and the different AGFA machines, in fact I think AGFA was one time was called Compu Graphic, you know, before I purchase Compu Graphic.
But they used to have these little desktop processing units that uh were about the size of a uh laser printer that you'd feed your cassettes through and it would develop your film uh or your paper type of uh media that would come out of the laser photo typesetters.
Oh, yeah.
Uh w would converting a piece of equipment like that be that uh far out of the question using uh developer and bleach?
I don't think so.
I mean I think uh it can be done.
Uh probably the the thing that you'd have to watch is what exact chemicals you use, because obviously they're uh the plumbing and what everything is made out of has a lot to do with whether you can or cannot use that particular machine to do a process.
Um so that that would be one of the things.
I I think that would probably be the the quickest and easiest way we would like to see moving forward into an actual system because um a lot of the bigger machines that do very large uh processes uh are kind of not being used anymore.
Yeah, yeah.
So they might be uh available for a song, let's say.
Yeah.
On eBay or whatnot.
Yeah, exactly.
And then just take them, clean them out.
And if you decide that you want to go with a route of uh D nineteen and some fixer, yeah.
Just feed your thirty by forty centimeter sheet.
You just have to figure out the timing that it needs to go through the rollers.
Exactly.
That's basically all you would have to do.
Yeah.
It's not really, really that hard.
So uh isn't that something?
Yeah.
I mean it is possible, and there's some people that have looked at it but haven't done a lot of work in it, but I think within the next uh the coming year um uh we're gonna be talking to quite a number of uh large uh producing holographers that are doing it for various display work and trying to get a system down that can be more automated.
Yeah, yeah.
Terrific.
You don't have any pricing together on any of the materials yet, do you?
Uh not specifically because we're again it's uh even though we said we were working on this for about a year, it's all coming to a head really fast right now.
Um I was looking at proposals and things like that, and I mean for your listeners uh as a uh you know four by five sheets, they would probably be running in the three to five dollar a piece range approximately.
That's as close as I can come to as as an estimate.
For film.
No no plans on plates, right?
Plates are are kind of uh a whole nother thing for us in that uh of course um the film is manufactured in Japan and uh the facility obviously is there to make uh lots of rolls of film or lots of sheets of film or what have you.
So their their expertise in coding is on a a thinner s flexible type of substrate.
Uh when you get into uh thicker plate substrates they do obviously have the technology because they uh coat uh some of the coatings for uh plasma screens and L C D screens.
I see but the the difficulty is of course those are uh the cost of those are are quite high.
Plus the shipping from Japan of plates is somewhat problematic because uh of damage and and things like that.
So I mean it's not out of the question.
I think we're gonna have to see how the film performs in the marketplace and what kind of demands we can get out of it.
Um if plates become an issue uh moving forward we will definitely consider that.
It's it's not that inexpensive anymore to have things manufactured in Japan, is no, no.
It's uh like everything else, yeah.
Costs are going up and uh resources are well, everything's kind of shifting to to China.
Yeah.
For all kinds of stuff.
Well I know twenty years ago a lot of the uh bicycle manufacturers they started to have their frames manufactured in Japan.
So if you bought a Raleigh or if you bought a Schwin, they were uh British and American companies but the actual frames, the uh production facilities had shifted to Japan.
And then of course you had your Jap Japanese makers like Fuji and whatnot making bicycles.
But then it got so expensive to manufacture the frames in Japan that even the Japanese bicycle companies now have their frames manufactured in Taiwan.
Yeah.
So if you buy a Fuji bicycle now, even though it's a Japanese uh company that frames manufactured in Taiwan.
Well it's a global economy.
Yeah, it's the same thing anymore anywhere.
Yeah.
Very interesting what is the thickness of the substrate?
Uh the total thickness of the film is about eight point nine mil mil.
Okay.
Uh the emulsion itself is about uh eight microns thick.
Yeah, I don't for for lack of memory right here I can't uh remember w how that compares to uh perhaps the Slavic film or the uh old Agva film as far as thickness.
I know Agva had a pretty nice uh thickness to it to work with and we have a back coat on the film to help reduce curl.
Okay.
Let me ask you basically that's not an antihalation back.
No, it's not.
Okay.
All right.
That's no, we found some people it's one of those things.
You can't have it on there if you're gonna try to have the film uh usable for for masters and transfers.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Alright, well you I did receive the first press release.
Do you have any other materials that you could send to me that I could place on the website for when people listen to the interview.
Um I have the uh the latest press release that we uh you know what's the date on your press release?
I'd have to pop it open on the screen.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Hope everything doesn't shut down on me.
We'll lose uh twenty minutes of uns uh show here.
Oh December twenty eighth, two thousand five latest press release okay how about if I put that up on the uh website.
That would be fine.
That's good.
Um I have uh provisional technique technical documentation um that could be uh probably put there it it really just provides what uh nanometer range it has where the safe lights should be uh what lasers can be used.
Response curves.
Uh response curves.
Yeah.
I have contacted a few people as far as uh their willingness to take this material and do a couple shots and give feedback on it.
Uh huh.
So if you'd like I can get that information to you.
Yeah that would be great.
And dare we say that if uh possibly maybe five the first five people that would want to contact you to get a sample to work with could do so?
Yes.
Okay.
I would say that we could easily do that at the first five people that contact me via email and uh J P L A C K O F U J I H U N T USA dot com.
And we'll send them uh a few sheets of four by five to try out.
Okay, and I'll also have that email address right on the website.
Now keep in mind folks, this is the first five people, not the first fifty five.
And of course this is a global show.
So you know, when this goes up online, whatever time it goes up, it's gonna go up.
I mean it's gonna if I put this up at eight o'clock at night, that's gonna make it as an advantage for some people, but for some other person around the world where it might be three o'clock in the morning and they're sleeping, they're gonna be out of luck.
So I can't luck with the draw, having three kids and trying to be fair with three kids all the time has led me to believe that you know what, it'll go up when it goes up and the first five people that contact gets the stuff.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, that's the way it's 'cause I can read the emails now.
That's not fair.
It was three o'clock in the morning here.
That's uh I'm sorry, that's the best I can do.
Yeah.
That's it.
Well, I want to thank you guys for lunch.
It was delicious.
Oh, you're very good.
I was actually over in in that area today, my wife and I went over to a uh a Bavarian restaurant that's uh over there to get some uh some uh knockworth deli food, yeah.
So uh Ryan over there.
Oh, it's an absolutely gorgeous day.
It's it's it's unbelievable.
I think we're gonna pay for this.
Yeah, probably pay for this weather.
Is there anything that you'd like like to add to this interview that we have not uh been that we've not talked about?
Uh I think uh that pretty much covers it uh that I could think of.
I mean, we're really excited about bringing this film to market.
Um we've had some uh uh famous people uh in the holographic community tested.
Do you want to give any information about those famous people?
Uh well we had Anna Maria Nicholson uh look at the film, we had Augie Mouth look at the film, um Dr.
Perry, John Perry at uh Hollow North look at the film on uh I can't think of any.
John Taylor, right?
Uh Rob Taylor, yes, yeah.
Uh Fourth Dimension um Oh, what was the the other game?
Sorry about that, Rob.
Uh triple take?
Triple take.
Oh no kidding.
And yeah, in California.
And uh Dinesh and Joy.
Yeah.
We've gotten uh really excellent feedback from everyone.
Uh they really like the film.
It looked good, it was uh good to work with.
Um it's gonna come in the size that they're looking at.
Uh what's nice is uh I mean we knew that the uh Agva material is basically getting to the end.
Uh not there's some out there still but very little, and for those that have a red Ruby Pulse, um if they needed a film to keep on making images and and this film will will help them do that.
So we're very excited about that.
And I guess lastly, if someone is out there, we'll say it's uh either John Smith or Sally Smith.
And they're already using materials and they've been using them for a while, why would they want to switch?
What is the incentive for them to switch over to Agva if they already have a protocol in place with uh other materials?
Well, I think it it gives you the opportunity to have a secondary supplier if issues arise.
Um it also gives it the opportunity to uh possibly use some of the newer low cost lasers that are out there if you're using an older system and you wanted to upgrade but um you know you were limited to the type of film you were using, this might give you the opportunity to upgrade to a different kind of uh possibly a cheaper, more powerful laser.
Um since it's a pan chromatic film, you have a wide range of different types of lasers to choose from.
And of course, uh Fuji is uh I would say the largest manufacturer of uh films in the world.
And uh you know, we can't make it right, nobody can.
And I think uh our quality speaks for itself, and we believe we'll have a uh high quality product that uh is consistent, the same emulsion to emulsion, and has a great shelf life and has a great uh image.
It has uh just a fabulous, bright, low noise, sharp, sharp hologram.
Yeah, it's very nice stuff to look at from what we could see under the conditions that we were in.
Yes, exactly.
I mean that's that speaks volumes for it.
Right.
It really does.
Yeah, so we're we're gonna actually introduce it uh the film at the uh Photonics West show in uh in San Jose, and we hope to uh also go to the International Symposium on display holography.
Oh, in Wales.
Uh in Wales.
Yeah.
We'll also actually uh we're hoping to have uh uh the work some work on display at uh the photo marketing association trade show in in um Orlando in February.
Oh that's nice too.
Yeah.
So I mean we're serious that that we know that the market has been uh let's say under serviced and we believe there is quite a potential out there for holography in not only the hobby world but also um for displays uh medical imaging uh mapping and the like and and we think our film i is the film that will be used in the future for those if Fuji's ever interested in putting a exhibit together using the Fuji materials uh for people to come to that would be a good idea too.
We probably would uh think about that once we get it rolling out in the market people are actually using it and making more and more holograms that we could you know you never know a sponsored show or an artist or the or the like there's so many artists out there right now it it's hard to say whose work we would uh we would like to sponsor but yeah anything is possible in the future.
Mm-hmm.
And when will you see Greg next?
And he's not sitting in the room with you right there.
No no he'll be here next week.
Okay he sent me a date tell him that if you if you can and and you see him tell him that the dates okay.
Okay.
All right.
I think February sometime.
I think uh eighth or something.
Yeah.
And then I'll get back to him on that.
But he he's not in touch with email or anything right now.
Oh yeah you could email.
Oh, is he okay.
All right.
I'll do that.
Alright, and then this show will probably go up later tonight, and I'll get the uh email.
I don't know if you're on the email list or not.
Um not sure.
Okay.
It's it's not where it is, though.
Yeah, it's it's the email list that goes out to uh everyone announcing that there's a new show.
Uh-huh.
So that announcement'll go out either later tonight or early tomorrow morning, depending on how much I get finished tonight.
I think I'm just going to use the show as is.
I don't even think anything needs to be edited on this.
It's not too much, I don't think.
No, just as is, put it up and we're ready to go and everybody can listen to it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sounds great.
All right, John, thank you very much for being on the show.
Well, thank you.
Thank you and Greg for lunch.
Had a great time and uh a lot of uh luck and success with your new holographic material and welcome to the club.
Thank you very much.
All right, talk to you later.
You have a good day.
Bye.
Bye bye.